gänsehaut moment für emanuel makro er
bleibt frankreichs präsident und in
paris gibt es für ihn die hölle mache
jetzt
[Musik]
steht der hand in hand mit
seiner ehefrau
am place de la république in paris
1 sieges moment
[Musik]
der moment den er sichtlich genießt
erleichtert
mit diesen momenten zwar hat die letzten
tage die letzten wochen waren hart es
war knapp gegen die rechtsextreme marine
le pen und am ende aber ein sieg für
emanuel makropulos mal geschafft so wird
erst erlebt haben dass das ergebnis ja
gerade mal so kann man sagen 58 prozent
bekommt er
41,8 prozent kommt bekommt marie le pen
der zehn prozentpunkte zugelegt und
darüber spricht man heute natürlich in
frankreich warum wollten so viele
menschen dort eine rechtsextreme das ist
die eine seite von frankreich die eine
seite dort in paris und gleichzeitig die
andere seite wütende proteste in
frankreich in vielen städten das ist in
lyon passiert vor dem rathaus dort das
wird beschossen mit feuerwerkskörpern
ähnliche bilder aus paris eine wütende
menge dort in der nacht am abend auf den
straßen viele gewalttätige
ausschreitungen auch in der nacht
gleichzeitig gab es natürlich bereits
schöne viele reaktionen aus dem ausland
denn wenn du sagen die ganze welt atmet
auf ursula von der leyen beispielsweise
hat ihre glückwünsche die präsidentin
der eu kommission dazu kommen lassen sie
schreibt lieber emanuel makro herzlichen
glückwunsch zu ihrer wiederwahl des
präsidenten republik ich freue mich auf
die fortsetzung unserer hervorragenden
zusammenarbeit gemeinsam werden wir
frankreich und europa zusammen bringen
natürlich auch seelands gehen genau er
ebenso sofort glückwünsche geschickt
nach paris auch der britische premier
boris johnson gratuliert auch unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz gratuliert
hatte vorjahr massiv geworben auch für
die wahl von emanuel makro also all das
passiert in diesen stunden uns bild
reporterin annika rage ist in paris hat
die letzten stunden dort noch näher
verfolgt als wir alle annika sagte
einmal über das was dort passiert also
einerseits die europäischen staats und
regierungschefs diese überschlagen alle
gratulieren alle geworben haben für
manuel makro und gleichzeitig ganz ganz
viele franzosen die ja genau das nicht
wollten
genau aus sicht der franzosen war immer
nur im makro sozusagen das geringste
übel denn man hat zwar gewonnen aber
trotzdem hatte auch gleichzeitig ein
gespaltenes land gewonnen der vorsprung
zu le pen war am ende größer als man
zunächst gedacht hat aber man darf nicht
vergessen micron hat gegen
praktisch gegen eine rechtspopulistin
gewonnen die millionen menschen gewählt
haben und millionen menschen haben
lieber eine rechtspopulisten gewählt
oder sich komplett enthalten anstelle
makro überhaupt zu wählen das heißt es
war eine totale charakter wahl zwei
verschiedene köpfe man hat sich dann
sozusagen für das geringste übel
entschieden werden hier mit einigen
menschen gesprochen die auch gesagt
haben was bleibt uns anderes übrig wir
haben aber gestern keinen wirklichen
wahlsieger gesehen hier hinter uns
hinter dem eiffelturm fand die wahlparty
statt micron ging auf die bühne aber er
gedemütigt und
er wusste natürlich dass die zahlen
keine guten waren das ist wirklich
horrorzahlen waren und ja ging dann
wirklich demütig und eher ruhig zur
bühne hat sich er gezeigt als jemand der
ganz genau weiß dass er eben dieses
gespalten erfolg vor sich hat
gleichzeitig lief arbeit ode an die
freude also die europahymne das war
natürlich auch gleichzeitig ein klarer
machtanspruch im agro hat also gezeigt
ich bin jetzt hier sozusagen einer der
anführer hier in europa und ich habe
hier in europa das sagen aber wie ich
schon gesagt habe er hat gegen eine
rechtspopulisten gewonnen eine klare
putin verehrerin und millionen menschen
haben einer frau eine stimme gegeben die
wie gesagt putin verehrt und während
putins panzer durch europa rollen haben
viele menschen dieser frau eine stimme
gegeben und dass es natürlich
beängstigend sind gemeinsam noch einmal
auf diese fotos der nacht schauen annika
besonders auf eines das zeigt makro mit
seiner frau brigitte auch sie ist immer
sich bei gestanden an diesem wichtigen
wahlabend hier sieht man wie er ihre
hand küsst du warst in diesem abend auch
in dieser szene dabei erzählen uns
einmal wie du diesen abend sie wurden
begleitet von mehreren kindern dort auf
die bühne du hast
also der abend war tatsächlich
spektakulär mit dass das ganze fand hier
hinter dem eiffelturm auf dem großen
platz statt es war eine große bühne
aufgebaut man hat den eiffelturm
erleuchten lassen es waren wirklich
tausende menschen da alle haben ihre
frankreich flaggen gehisst und in die
höhe gehalten aber trotzdem war zu
wirklich zufrieden waren die menschen
nicht wie gesagt mark und seine frau
haben händchen gehalten hinter ihnen
ging eine schar von kindern man war ich
glaube einfach sehr erleichtert dass es
mal krank geworden ist und nicht le pen
die rechtspopulistin aber zufrieden ist
man mit dieser wahl nicht und man hofft
dass es ja zur nächsten wahlperiode dann
andere kandidaten gibt annika rausch und
zugeschaltet aus paris vielen herzlichen
dank